[Music]
all right thank you Malcolm X when he
got up to speak places you see sometimes
say I see some friends and I even see
some enemies and I'm glad to stay I only
see friends here glad to see so many of
you all here today I've been asked to
speak around the issue of disarmament
and building bombs versus building
houses and housing and so I stand before
you today to declare that instead of
building bombs we need to build a
housing affordable housing yes
affordable housing in good neighborhoods
with well-funded schools
plenty of public park space and street
lights that come on when the Sun Goes
Down see I had the privilege of growing
up in a neighborhood like that in the
80s and 90s and ever West Side of
Manhattan in New York City I lived on
the fourth floor of a 12-story pre-war
building and for the younger folks here
pre-war men pre-world War Two was built
in 1927 pre-world War two apartment
building that sat on Riverside Drive and
looked out over the Hudson River I could
come out the front door of the apartment
building and walk across the street to
the Riverside Park I will go down there
and play Little League and spend
countless hours over the years that I
grew up what you need to know is I was
raised by a single mother who taught
elementary school-aged children the New
York City Public Schools for over 35
years and she raised me and my older
sister with little to no help from
either of our fathers and without the
kind of resources that would have
allowed her to stay in a neighborhood
like that if it wasn't for this
ingenious invention called rent
regulations rent regulations my mother
moved into the fourth floor
of that apartment building in the late
1960s and she is still there to this day
in that same apartment in New York City
there are two categories of rent
regulated apartments some are in the
category of rent controlled which means
that whatever the wrench is when you
move into that apartment building is
what the rent is today and forever
and those that are rent stabilized which
means the rent can only go up by small
and modest increments every year that
apartment has been rent stabilized that
she has lived in since the late 1960s
now unlike what I will call I hope it
doesn't offend anybody the tragic
failure of the renter coalition here in
the Commonwealth of Massachusetts in the
1990s to keep rent regulations from
being lifted in the Commonwealth in New
York City those rental coalitions are
strong and they protect what is becoming
an increasingly modest supply of rent
regulated apartments that remain as
tenants die out and there is no family
member to assume their leash because in
New York City there is a thing called
secession and you can secede your family
members lease to rent control to rent
stabilized apartments what I'm here to
tell you today is that I am of the
belief that it is time for Boston time
for Cambridge and time for every other
economically diverse community in this
area and in this country to get serious
about building affordable housing
protecting affordable housing and making
it possible for every young kid no
matter how marginal their circumstances
to grow up like I did in a good
neighborhood with well funded schools
penny of public park space and lights
that come on at night on the streets
as a matter of moral justice those
communities should not be limited to the
white wealthy to the privileged or to
the rich and at this stage of the game
what I have referred to as the final
stages of gentrification in a place like
Cambridge that is who they are limited
to white the wealthy the privileged and
the rich the reality is that well-funded
public schools bring opportunity publics
park spaces bring activities and fond
memories and street lights that come on
when the Sun Goes Down
after safety and security and stability
in neighborhoods so affordable housing
is really about more than giving a man a
home as Ben Harper sings it is about
opportunity it is about the possibility
for equality and it is about providing
everyone with a chance to flourish in
life as the effort is like to see and so
we have to get serious about
articulating this wider vision for why
affordable housing is a moral imperative
a moral issue not a partisan issue not a
Republican or Democrat a right or left
issue but a moral issue and we need to
get serious about executing that vision
by as Malcolm X would say whatever means
unnecessary in order to get it done
we've got to stop fooling around trying
to negotiate with developers for a few
more units here and a few more units
there in the buildings that they put up
to make a killing when they start
charging $1,500 a month for 800 square
feet that I could turn around in twice
maybe we've got to stop fooling around
trying to leverage community benefits
agreement money that somehow seems to
have a hard time making a real tense in
the issue an abundant supply of
affordable housing is not something that
we should
be asking for as a favor but instead
demanding as a right for all Americans
native-born or otherwise so while Trump
rattle sabers with his alter ego in
North Korea Kim jong-un we need to be
insisting on keeping our priorities
straight here at home it is time to
build housing and not bombs it is time
to make my reality my childhood on the
Upper West Side of Manhattan in a
neighborhood with well-funded public
schools and plenty of public park space
and streetlights that came on at night
is time to make my childhood and my
reality not the exception for people who
aren't white rich privileged or wealthy
but the norm for every child in this
country in every community in every
neighborhood around America thank you
[Applause]
[Music]